RIGHT NOW, IN UKRAINE, THOUGH,
MORE LOSS OF LIFE AND
DESTRUCTIONS AN ELECTRICIAN AND
WATER AFTER A NEW ONSLAUGHT OF
RUSSIAN MISSILE ATTACKS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, INCLUDING KYIV.
AT LEAST SAY A RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING IN THE CAPITAL WAS HIT,
KILLING 3 PEOPLE.
AUTHORITIES REPORTS EVERY
REGION IN UKRAINE IS SEEING
POWER OUTAGES.
KYIV HAS ALSO SUSPENDED WATER
SERVICE ON THE POWER UNITS AT 3
NUCLEAR PLANTS HAVE BEEN
SWITCHED OFF DUE TO THE
ATTACKS.
CNN SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MATTHEW CHANCE
AND NOTICE ON THE BLACK SEA.
MATTHEW, UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS
SAYING EARLIER THAT'S THE
ENTIRE REGION WAS WITHOUT
POWER.
WHAT'S THE SITUATION NOW?
WHAT ARE THE DETAILS ON THE
GROUND.
>> WELL, THE SITUATION HERE IN
OUR DATA IS PRETTY BLEAK.
IT'S ONE OF THE AREAS THAT'S
BEEN VERY BADLY AFFECTED BY THE
RUSSIAN MISSILE STRIKES ON
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE, TARGETS,
AND RIGHT BEHIND ME, THE CITY
IS ALMOST IN COMPLETE DARKNESS.
PEOPLE OF GENERATORS, OF COURSE,
AND THEY ARE PROVIDING THEIR
OWN ELECTRICITY AS MUCH AS THEY
CAN, BUT IN GENERAL, IT IS A
VERY DARK CITY, WHICH IS SORT
OF BRACING ITSELF FOR FURTHER
ATTACKS IN THE FUTURE.
THERE'S BEEN A WAVE OF MISSILE
STRIKES JUST OVER THE COURSE OF
THE PAST FEW HOURS, NOT JUST IN
THIS REGION BUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
YOU MENTIONED THE KYIV REGION
AROUND THE CAPITAL BEING STRUCK
AS WELL, WITH 3 PEOPLE KILLED
THERE.
CAUSING DAMAGE TO MISSILE
STRIKES TO A RESIDENTIAL AREA
ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF THE RUSSIAN
CAPITAL.
BUT ALSO IN CENTRAL UKRAINE AS
WELL, A HORRIFIC ATTACK BY A
RUSSIAN MISSILE ON A MATERNITY
CLINIC OR HOSPITAL IN WHICH A
SMALL CHILD, A SMALL BABY, WAS
KILLED JUST A COUPLE OF DAYS
OLD.
THE MOTHER AND THE DOCTOR WERE
PULLED OUT OF THE RUBBLE ALIVE,
BUT THE CHILD LOST THEIR LIFE.
.
ANOTHER INDICATION OF JUST HOW
GRIM AND BRUTAL AND FULL OF
BLOOD THIS CONFLICT HAS BECOME.
IT ALL COMES, OF COURSE, AMID
THAT CONCERTED CAMPAIGN BY
RUSSIA TO TARGET RUSSIAN --
UKRAINIAN, SORRY,
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS TO
REALLY PLUNGE THE COUNTRY INTO
DARKNESS AND INTO COLD.
THIS AS THE TEMPERATURES REALLY
START TO PLUNGE AS WELL.
IN THE BEGINNING OF THE WINTER,
HERE, THE FIRST SNOWS HAVE
SETTLED OVER MUCH OF THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S WHEN ENERGY REQUIREMENTS
ARE AT THEIR HIGHEST.
SO, WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS POINT,
EVEN THOUGH AUTHORITIES ARE
DOING ALL THEY CAN TO RESTORE
ENERGY CONNECTIONS, IT'S
LOOKING LIKE THE PROSPECT OF A
VERY COLD, DARK WINTER IN THE
MONTHS AHEAD, BECKY.
>> AND WHAT PROSPECTS OF A
SOLUTION TO ALL OF THIS, AND
END OF THIS WAR AT THIS POINT,
MATTHEW?
>> I DON'T THINK, UNLESS I'VE
MISSED SOMETHING, WE'RE LOOKING
AT MUCH OF A PROSPECT OF THAT
THE MOMENT.
I SEEMS BOTH SIDES ARE DIGGING
IN, TRYING TO HOLD ON TO THE
TERRITORY THEY'VE GOT AT THE
MOMENT AS WE APPROACH THOSE
WINTER MONTHS WHERE THE
FIGHTING WILL INEVITABLY
DECREASE IN ITS INTENSITY.
THAT IS BECAUSE THE
TEMPERATURES ARE EXPECTED TO GO
SO LOW, PERHAPS AS LOW AS MINUS
20 DEGREES CENTIGRADE IN SOME
PARTS OF UKRAINE.
AND IT'S ALSO THE FACT THAT
BOTH SIDES HAVE KIND OF MINIMUM
CONDITIONS, IF YOU LIKE, FOR
PEACE TALKS TO TAKE PLACE.
BUT NEITHER SIDE ARE WILLING TO
MEET THOSE CONDITIONS OF THE
OTHER.
UKRAINE, AT THIS POINT, FEELS
IT HAS BEEN TAKEN TERRITORY IN
SIGNIFICANT QUANTITIES FROM THE
RUSSIAN OCCUPYING FORCES, AND
IT IS IN NO MOVE TO MAKE
COMPROMISES WHEN IT COMES TO
TERRITORY.
FOR THEIR PART, THE RUSSIANS,
THEY FEEL THEY HAVEN'T STARTED
OR COMPLETED THINGS I HAVE TO
DO IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE CONDITIONS ARE NOT THERE AT
THE MOMENT.
THE POLITICAL WILL IS NOT THERE
THE MOMENT FOR SERIOUS
NEGOTIATION.
>> MATTHEW CHANCE IS ON THE
GROUND AND OTA IN UKRAINE.
MATTHEW, THANK YOU.